[Music]  i'm jetta diabeela  i've hosted and co-hosted cable news  shows network tv shows all of it  i hated the filters and there were many  i struggled with the time constraints  that stifled conversation it sometimes  felt like i was drowning in producer  direction  what i wanted was to get to the heart of  big issues to be real and to have an  honest conversation with people who  agreed with me and disagreed with me  people who would make us think and help  fix what's broken  i couldn't do what i wanted to do what i  needed to do in the spaces i was in  so i was ready to find a new space  i believe so strongly in individual  freedom i love this country but it's a  mess right now and i'm not going to  sugarcoat that with fake giggles and  rainbows i want to talk about why things  are so [ __ ] up not just in politics  but everywhere health fitness dating  culture it all needs a good hard look  welcome to my new zone this is jetta  diablo live on valuetainment